Talking about this certain percentage of the word beings.
Half of Brazil has the,
he has the brain worm that makes you basically psychotic.
Well,
it doesn't make you psychotic and risk taking crazy.
It affects your judgment.
This is toxic programs.
You'd want to have more catch Mel Piss.
Yes.
Well it definitely does that to,
to rats.
It actually reprograms rat's brains makes them sexually attracted as much
parasites.
Yes.
There's a bunch of them and there's some that probably haven't even been
identified.
That's where the whole crazy cat lady thing comes from.
Yes,
that's exactly what it is.
It's one of the reasons why they tell women when they're pregnant to stay the
fuck away from cat litter.
Don't touch cat litter.
Don't get on with your baby cats.
Yes,
you,
I mean it's,
it can be actually fatal for babies,
but what I'm trying to get yelled at him cash.
Well I'm sure there's a lot of factors there,
right?
She old wives tales were like,
you get demon possessed by that cat and it really,
it's a damn brain worm.
Well.
That's probably also why they told you not to eat pork.
And that's a real brain worm programming you,
like you were saying earlier,
it's true.
I looked,
I didn't know that at the top soccer teams have the highest level of brain worm
infestation.
Well,
it's,
there's a disproportionate amount of con people that live in countries where the
high toxoplasmosis infection would say it's successful soccer teams.
There was some study that was done on that where we had a doctor,
Robertson women that more sexually promiscuous.
They just,
yes,
it's recklessness.
Yes.
And they think that men are more reckless and that's why there's a
disproportionate amount of motorcycle victims that test positive for
toxoplasmosis.
This is where the Robert Sapolsky at Stanford University was telling us,
is there a way to remove,
I don't think they're right.
Warm.
Yeah.
I don't think there is.
Well,
you know,
there's like snails that get a brain one that programs that go to the top of a
tree shall birds eat it.
Yeah.
And then,
and then it's crapped out in the snails.
Eat that and then go and then just food cycle.
Yes.
Show how,
don't tell me and classic evolution.
And I'm also believe the interpretation by,
by right wingers of the Bible,
that's not what it says.
But obviously evolution.
There's a big quick jumps,
but we know what's going on.
But the idea that just,
there's worms and there's all these different,
talking about the one that gets into a grasshopper,
the aquatic worm gets inside of a grasshopper's body and gets the grasshopper to
commit suicide,
gets a grasshopper to jump into water and drown and then it comes out of its
body.
And that's where it lives.
It lives in the water.
So it literally gets its host to commit.
So that chain of events,
how does that evolve where suddenly a worm gets in the grasshopper and does
something,
a super computer,
couldn't do it.
Programs to drowned itself?
Well,
this is a matter of complex biology.
I mean,
so I think it's insanely complex and it's something that scientists are studying
on a daily basis.
You're going to get through that and coming up,
cause I'm gonna,
I don't want you to talk about me all day.